[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  there's not a day that doesn't happen  where I'm not looking at a piece of  garbage on the side of the road or  thinking about an empty shopping or  going to a junkyard or something like  that because it's these places where you  can find old items that have a little  bit of a history they might not work  perfectly so they might rattle a little  bit more squeak a little bit more and  those are interesting props for Foley  artists to work with  [Music]  [Music]  we wanted to get the sound of the  ringing metal of the blade without  getting the scraping sound that's  usually associated with sword Zing's I  discovered that by picking a specific  type of metal that was actually a shelf  support I could use a cello bow and bow  the side of the metal and wave it around  that kind of gave the sword that was  being moved a magical quality to it  [Music]